the i-team following threats of violence
being made
online now those planned armed events
leading up to inauguration day they
never materialize but still
the concerns about them were very real
the i-team's david charns joining us now
and david i know you talked exclusively
with the head of the fbi here in the
valley
yeah denise local and federal police
remain on alert and they need your help
the head of the fbi here in the valley
says most of the tips his agency looks
into
actually start when we see something odd
and pick up the phone
let us take a look at it let us make an
evaluation
see something say something we've heard
it since 9 11.
now fbi special agent in charge aaron
rouse says your eyes are his team's ears
to what's happening online
when you turn to violence you've lost
any kind of
legitimacy to whatever cause you may be
supporting
the fbi has arrested more than 100
people since the washington d.c capitol
riot two weeks ago
the agency receiving tips from friends
and family of many of those arrested
but before something happens what does
it take for the fbi to step
in when you turn to violence when you
turn to destruction
that's when your first amendment
privilege is stopped and you're no
longer a protester
you're a criminal the i-team confirms
the fbi was forwarded to local cases
the night county republican party
chair's letter posted after the riot
citing unproven claims of voter fraud
and that quote
the next 12 days will be something to
tell the grandchildren
it's 1776 all over again the chair now
asking for donations to a legal defense
fund and just last week the i-team
reported on a website
also out of nye county called trump's
army it offered a free four-day
defensive handgun course at the front
sight firearms training institute
if you signed up for a newsletter about
election fraud
since the i-team's report last week the
site was scrubbed
rouse wouldn't talk specifics but said
there's always a discussion about what
goes too far if somebody is advocating
actual
violence actual violence against
somebody else that's when they've
crossed the line
now rouse would not say if his office is
actually pursuing any action in those
night county cases but we did confirm
with local authorities in night county
that
both the letter and the website were
forwarded to the federal agency
i'm david charns 8 news now denise
all right good work david did um did rao
say if maybe the fbi has just been
overwhelmed with all kinds of tips about
maybe people's behavior online
well we didn't get a number from him but
he did say he'd rather get a thousand
phone calls or online tips that go
anywhere
then miss that one tip that could
prevent something awful for happening
and
just in case you don't know the number
for the fbi and calling in a tip is
really easy to remember
it is 1-800 call fbi